(thoughtful music)
- Okay, greetings. Happy Thursday.
Welcome. You guys have an
exam a week from today.
We've been talking about the TAs,
about the kinds of things that
are going to be on the exam.
It'll be very straightforward.
Some IDs, some dates, some
short answers, some essays.
You'll have a choice among questions.
You should think about, like...
Think about what question you would ask.
One way to study is think about
what question you would ask.
Like, what sorts of
things are the big themes?
And then practice answering it.
Maybe, like, pair up.
Have three people. Divide.
Think about what the big
questions are so far.
I'm not going to ask you
about the first few lectures.
The first few lectures
are to help you think
about what it is like to
be involved in history.
The subject of the exam are the events
from roughly the ninth century
to roughly the seventh century.
So the thing we're doing today
is we're taking a deep breath.
We're taking a deep breath. Yeah.
I mean, at this point in this semester,
maybe we should all
physically take a deep breath,
a few deep breaths.
I'm not going to do that
because I'm very conscious
about how that's going to look.
Professor leads cult at Yale.
(students laughing)
Makes students perform
breathing exercises.
But what we're doing
is, to change metaphors,
what we're doing is we're
going to zoom back today
and we're going to think
about empire in general
and empire in the world.
And the reason why
there's no handout today
is that this lecture is really much more
about situating the events
in Ukraine in world history,
because without world history,
it doesn't make a lot of sense,
and let me just give you three reasons
why I think this is true.
Number one is the point
that we have reached
in the class chronologically,
where we are now working
in the period of 1500, 1600,
where we are really in the
Age of Exploration, right?
We're in the Age of Discovery,
which coincides with the
Renaissance in European history.
We are in the period where
Europeans are looking
for trade routes, finding
lands that are new to them,
discovering them, from their
point of view, of course,
making claims on them, setting
up these new trade routes,
destroying states that already exist,
doing all these very important things
which for the first time make
of the world a single unit.
So obviously the world
is always a single unit.
There's always weather.
People are always moving.
But somewhere around the age
of 15 or around the year 1500,
the pace of this picks up, right?
The pace of this picks up so that events
on one side of the world can affect people
on the other side of the world,
not on the scale of thousands
of years or hundreds of years,
but on the scale of, let's say, one year.
So in your lifetime,
multiple things that happened
on the other side of the
world could actually affect
what happened to you, right?
So there's a change in pace.
There's another change in
pace in the 19th century,
another change in pace in the 21st.
But this is a very important thing,
a kind of first globalization,
if you'll indulge that.
And I'll give you some examples
of what I'm talking about
from our own little corner.
When we think about, for example,
the British trying to
find a passage to China,
to the East, through the Arctic Ocean,
which, let's face it, shows
creativity if nothing else...
And there isn't one yet.
I mean, you know, in you guys' lifetime,
there are going to be plenty of passages
through the Arctic that there aren't now.
But in 1555, there wasn't,
and the British then
stumbled upon Muscovy,
and that opens up a trade route
where suddenly Muscovy
is trading with Britain,
which means trading with the
world in a westerly direction.
And then by 1647 or so,
the Muscovites have
reached the Pacific Ocean.
So in that century, suddenly, Muscovy,
which is becoming Russia, of course,
Muscovy is connected to
both the Atlantic Ocean
and the Pacific Ocean, and
that's one of the reasons
why Russia becomes the
state that it becomes,
is that Russia manages
to have an Atlantic and
a Pacific connection
as the world is becoming connected, right?
And that's one of the ways
that Russia is distinct from,
let's say, the
Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth
or the Kazakh state that we'll
be talking about on Tuesday.
By the way, on Tuesday,
I'm going to pick up where
we left off, roughly 1648,
and we are going to talk
about the Crimean Tatars.
We're going to talk
about the Ottoman Empire.
We're going to bring that into
encounter with Russia. Okay.
So the timeline that
we are on is coinciding
with a much bigger timeline.
If we think of 1648 as the
moment of the Kazakh rebellion,
1648 is also roughly the moment
when a Muscovite explorer,
this guy Dezhnev, gets
to the Pacific Ocean
and actually crosses into North America
as the first person to
do so in that direction,
at least in the modern period.
Obviously it'd been done before
or there wouldn't be
people in North America,
but that's a different story.
So we are thinking about
how our events connect
to world history, and we don't
really have a choice, right?
It's not that I'm trying
to be cool and avant garde
with this global history
thing, which is, by the way,
it's not cool and avant garde anymore.
It's that these events
don't actually make sense.
So in the next lecture, for example,
in 1721, Russia is going to be,
Muscovy is going to be
renamed the Russian Empire
at almost exactly the same time
that Moscow bans Ukrainians
from selling grain except
through Muscovite ports, right?
Those two events are connected,
right? They're connected.
The fact that it is Moscow
that's controlling the
world trade of grain
from the most fertile part of Europe,
namely Ukraine, is very important.
The myth of what Russia is,
which we're also contending with,
has to do not just with
claiming the name Russia.
It also has to do with
controlling the land.
And I'm sure you can see the
connection to the present war.
It's 2022,
and those two things are
still very much connected.
If it's Russia, then of course
there's nothing wrong with
Russia controlling the land
and controlling the export of grain.
Okay, so the first reason is
that we can't really make sense
of what's happening unless we connect it,
at least in a very preliminary
way, to world history.
The second reason is
that this is also a time
of the intellectual reconfiguration
of how people see themselves in the world,
which I realize is a
very, very big notion,
and I'm going to have to
give it to you very briefly.
But thus far, when we
think about geography,
we've been thinking about geography
in terms of what classical authors knew
and how classical authors
described the world
and how land explorers in our part
of the world describe the world.
But basically, the framework
of the people who, you know,
who we're talking about is an
ancient Greco-Roman framework,
and the maps of Ukraine,
such as they were,
were from, you know, Ptolemy or Herodotus.
And if you remember,
the ancient Greeks had this nice habit
of projecting things onto Ukraine,
like, so griffins and
fields of gold and so on,
which weren't, like...
They had some basis in reality.
The Scythians actually
did make beautiful things
out of gold, which are
currently being plundered.
But the notion is that
the Greeks projected,
you know, a lot of things
that sort of happened
onto the territories
that they didn't know.
The Age of Exploration is also a time
when the Poles are mapping Ukraine.
We're going to get...
So we've talked about Polish colonization.
You can't separate
colonization from mapping.
The Poles and other
people are mapping Ukraine
in the 16th and 17th centuries.
And by the way, the word
they use for it is Ukraine.
The Poles say Ukraine.
The whole idea of Ukraine
is not a new idea at all,
as I'm sure you've already understood.
But in this mapping which the Poles do,
they are going beyond classical knowledge,
going beyond classical knowledge,
which is a very important thing
locally but also globally,
because classical knowledge
did not include something
which is very important about the world
and which Copernicus, you know,
was the person to actually get clear,
which is that our world
is actually not especially interesting.
I mean, okay, it's interesting
from our point of view,
because here we are, right?
But it's not interesting in the sense
that it's the center of anything.
The sun doesn't orbit around it.
Everything doesn't orbit around it.
It turns out we're not
the center of the world,
which is a discovery, frankly,
that's still sinking in,
you know, many centuries later.
But the age of discovery of
the world is also the age
of discovery that the world is
not the center of everything.
So there are major
intellectual transformation
happening at the same time, right?
There's a kind of loss of innocence.
The same moment when Europeans
are discovering in the world,
they're also discovering or
trying to take in the reality
that the world that they're
discovering is not the center
of the universe.
So that's a lot to happen, right?
That's a lot to happen,
and I think it's just,
it's worth bearing in mind.
The third reason why I'm going
to give you this very general introduction
to empire as world
history is that a thought
that we're meant to be having
over the course of this
class is how Ukraine
might bridge European
history and global history.
A major theme of European history
and global history is
the theme of colonialism,
and in this story, it's the
Europeans who are colonizing
and it's the rest of the
world who is being colonized.
But do we want it to be that simple,
or should we look closely about
and see who is colonizing
who in an empirical way?
It's hard to get away
from the impression that,
both in the early modern and,
as we'll see, the modern periods,
the idea of being colonized
applies pretty well to Ukraine,
although it's sitting there
in the middle of Europe.
When the Russian Empire
becomes the Russian Empire,
when it defines itself as an empire,
well, what's the center,
and what is the periphery?
But of course,
there are some interesting
twists to all this too,
which, again, are relevant
to the present situation.
What does it mean to become an empire
and to colonize Europe, right?
What does that mean?
There's a lot of ambiguity in that.
So there's no question
from the point of view
of the 18th century or, for that matter,
the 21st, that Moscow's perspective
on Ukraine is in some way colonial.
But what does it mean to colonize a place
which you also recognize came before you
in some important sense?
What does it mean to colonize
a place which you recognize
as being more European than yourself?
That is not so common, right?
That is not so common.
And if you grasp that, then
it's a little bit easier
to get your mind around
the weird ambiguities
and ambivalences that are
involved even in the discussion
of Ukraine on Russian television in 2022.
And then the final thing
is that when we get
to the modern period, or the
20th century, the 21st century,
which we will get to, I promise,
a major question of world history is,
and American history, for that matter,
is what do you do after empire, right?
What do you do after empire?
And one way to look at this conflict
that is happening now between Russia
and Ukraine is in that framework.
What do you do after empire,
where one answer can be "Let's
have more empire," right?
One answer can be "Let's
concentrate all kinds
of imperial thought and try
them out in the 21st century."
And then there can be another answer,
which I think is the Ukrainian answer,
which is "Look for something
that is not anti-imperial
but which is some way post-imperial."
And I'll talk more about
that, but it's worth thinking
about that big question of
what happens after empire.
Okay. So what is empire?
What's an empire?
Very briefly, we've talked about this,
I'll give you two very simple
ways to think about empire.
One is that it's the
opposite of a republic.
So if you remember the last lecture,
the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth...
In Polish, it's the Jrzeczpospolita.
It's a (speaking in Polish)
or (speaking in Polish).
It's a republic,
which means it's a common matter, right?
Oh, America's supposed to
be a republic, by the way.
And the thing about republics
is that republics are
meant to have a group.
Now, that group might not
be everybody, and usually,
it's not, but there is a group
of people who have rights,
as opposed to, for example, on autocracy.
This notion that a republic
and an empire are in some kind
of dialectic, of course,
comes from Rome, right?
This is a Roman notion.
You have a republic.
What happens to your republic?
It falls and it becomes an empire.
So George Lucas didn't invent that, right?
That whole pattern of politics
where you have a republic
and it's very flawed, and,
like, the parliamentarism,
it's really boring, and, like,
there's all this bureaucracy,
and then someone comes
and he has quick solutions
and maybe a cloak.
All plagiarized, right?
Like, this whole notion of a republic,
the republic that fails
and becomes an empire,
that's a classic historical trope.
And then even the notion that the people
who want to restore the
republic are doing so
because of some kind of
commitment to ideals,
which is the whole theme of
the movies I'm talking about,
that is also very familiar
from history, right?
The notion that...
Well, maybe I can't actually
justify the republic institutionally,
but a republic has a moral
advantage over an empire, right?
That's an argument which
is also 2000 years old
at the very least.
Okay, so second definition of empire
is that you can find a
center and a periphery.
So in an empire, you
know where the center is,
and the center is politically superior to
and economically exploitative
of the periphery.
Okay. So Rome is the paradigm of all this.
I'm now going to spend just a few minutes
reviewing some of the things that we know
about the first thousand
years of this class,
but within this framework.
So the Roman Empire...
We did all this.
Does it fall?
Does it not fall?
Depends on your point of view, right?
From the point of view
of what the Franks say
and then what, you know, the
European Renaissance says,
it fell and then it was
recreated as the Frankish state
and then intellectually as
the Renaissance later on.
From an East European point of view,
of course, Rome doesn't fall.
Byzantium is the Roman empire,
and Byzantium lasts until 1453.
And in our class, the way we're thinking
about the emergence of
East European states
and in particular Kyiv and
Rus is that there's contact
between these two empires, Byzantium,
which is clearly an
empire, the Frankish state,
which later calls itself
the Carolingian Empire,
which just means the Charles-ian Empire,
they're coming into contact,
they're competing politically
but also in terms of missionaries,
conversion to Christianity,
and that there's a third interesting force
that comes in between them,
which are the Vikings, right?
That is our story of state creation,
and it has to do with empire.
Now, here is where we get
into a very important point
which I'm going to emphasize later.
These empires are associated
with a monotheistic religion.
And of course, the thing
which makes Christendom
or the thing which makes
Europe is that it is one,
it's one dominant monotheistic
religion and not others.
The ancient world is a
Mediterranean world, right?
The ancient Christian world
is a Mediterranean world.
Christendom or Europe is
the world which happens
not only after Islam but
after Islam in general fails
to get through the Pyrenees on one side
and through the Caucasus.
I say in general because of course
there are huge exceptions, right?
Like the Bulgar Tatar state,
which then becomes
later the Kazan khanate,
which today is Tatarstan
and Russia, right?
But in general,
the idea is that Christendom
is going to be northerly
and Islam is going to be
southerly, in general.
And so these monotheistic states
recognize one another
as monotheistic states,
and they recognize their own peoples
as people who you do not enslave.
This notion of statehood is so fundamental
that it often gets overlooked.
When we talk about the state,
we often go very quickly
into very reified things
about what the state might be,
but one basic notion of a
state is that a state is a zone
in which you do not enslave
your own people, right?
So the larger the state
is, the larger the zone
in which you do not
enslave your own people,
of course, which raises
interesting questions
about when the United States
becomes a state, right?
Or when the United States
becomes a republic,
just to give you a very
familiar territory.
But one way to think about state formation
is that you have elites
that are no longer enslaving
the people around them
but instead are comfortable
having them work the land
and taxing them, right?
Having some people work
the land and be taxed,
have other people work the land
and become the warrior
class, roughly speaking.
So that's what a state means,
and that's going to be very
important as we move through,
because always in the back of your mind,
you should have the theme
of slavery, because slavery,
it's not some kind of marginal topic.
It's not something you have to
kind of sneak in at the end.
Slavery and statehood work
together very carefully.
Slavery and recognition work
together very, very carefully.
Like, this theme, which
is a major theme still
in the history of the United
States in the 21st century,
about who is recognized
as belonging to the state,
has everything to do with slavery
and the history of slavery.
What I'm trying to suggest
is that this is actually a very old theme.
It goes back to what the purpose
of a state was from the start.
Okay, so now I want to
remind you of the Mongols,
but in a slightly different way.
So we're going to talk more about this
on Tuesday, but the...
If I'm going too fast,
you can just stop me
and say, "I need to take a breath
because you promised deep breaths.
I need a deep breath."
You can just say that and I'll...
Okay, sorry. Cult thing.
Gotta stop. All right.
But no, seriously, if you
have a question, just,
and need me to pause,
just ask and I'll pause.
Yes?
- [Student] So, like, these states,
obviously they don't enslave people,
but if they're doing things like Russia
where it's, like, all serfdom-
- Yeah.
- How is that much different?
- Right, no, so that's a
very interesting question.
So if you enslave... Good.
If you enslave, that generally involves,
not always, but it
generally involves mobility.
So I'm about to talk about one
of the biggest slave markets
in Europe, which is Kaffa in
the 14th century in Crimea.
So slavery involves, not always,
but often involves mobility
and commerce, so I
enslave you, which means
I can take you somewhere and
sell you, whereas serfdom
fundamentally is about
binding people to the land.
So if I own serfs or own souls,
I don't actually have the
right to round them up
and sell them to my neighbor.
What I do have is the right to say
they cannot leave my land.
But you're right to raise that.
I mean, that's another question
which redounds over the
centuries in these comparisons
between Russia and the United States,
where people who are concerned
with serfdom were reading
the American abolitionist
literature and vice versa,
and there's a whole interesting
literary story there.
So thanks for that question.
So it speaks to what it
means to belong to a state.
So did the serfs belong
to the Muscovite state?
Right? Okay.
So again, that's another...
A third way to think about
republics and empires is,
if it's a republic, then theoretically,
you can belong to the state.
Not everybody does.
In an empire, mmm, there's not really,
that promise is not really contained
in the notion of the state.
All right, so let's
think about the Mongols,
but now in a slightly different way.
The Mongols, as you know,
come in and lay waste
to what remains of Kyiv and
Rus in the 13th century,
and then they stick around,
and they stick around in their state,
which is called the Golden Horde,
breaks up into various other states,
including the Crimean Khanate,
which we're going to talk more
about in the next lecture.
But the moment that I want to
pause on here is in the 1340s
where something very important happens,
and it has to do with slavery.
So the most important
or one of the most important centers
of the slave trade was a city which used
to be known as Theodosius
but which at the time
in the 14th century is known
as Kaffa, K-A-F-F-A, Kaffa,
on the eastern edge of
the Crimean Peninsula.
And at this time in the 14th century,
it is the Genoese
who are trading in Crimea.
So when we do the history of Crimea,
this is all going to become clear,
but when people talk about,
like, what Crimea always was,
that's extremely suspicious,
because Crimea has been a whole,
even compared to the rest of Ukraine,
it's been a whole lot of things
in a very interesting sequence.
But in the 14th century, it
is the Italian city states,
and in particular Genoa, that
are dominating the trade,
and, you know, either by
purchasing or by force,
are trying to control
some of the territory
which belongs to the local khanate.
So there is a battle in the 1340s
between Genoa and
between the Golden Horde,
and according to history,
although it's a little
bit too good to be true,
it's one of these things
that's a little bit good to be true,
the way the Black Death spreads...
Have you heard this story?
The way the Black Death spreads
is that the people on the side
of the Golden Horde are
dying of the Black Death.
This is 1346, 1347.
And so in order to...
So they invent biological weaponry.
Again, as I say, slightly too
good to be true, this story.
And they catapult the corpses
of their own dead soldiers
and commanders over the
walls against the Genoese.
And this spreads the Black Death,
and then the Genoese spread
it throughout Europe.
Okay, that happened, but the reason
why it's a little too good to be true
is that, of course,
there were other routes
by which the Black Death
could enter Europe.
I'm sure there was...
There wasn't only one vector.
You've now all lived how this works.
Like, there isn't...
There doesn't have to be
just one plane from China.
There are probably
going to be more vectors
of how the disease spreads.
Ah, nods of recognition.
But I want to spread
this because I want to...
I don't want to spread it.
(students laughing)
I want to convey this because
it helps us to see a moment
where we have the Golden Horde,
we have the Europeans in the 14th century,
and we have a very important change,
which is that roughly a third
of Western Europe is going
to die of this disease.
So roughly a third of the population
is going to be wiped out.
And this is very important
for our Age of Exploration,
which is what we're trying to set up now.
After so much of the European
population is wiped out
and avenues are cleared for innovation...
This is an optimistic story
of what happens after
a plague, by the way.
So after avenues are
cleared for innovation
and social advancement and
after traditional barriers
for changing ways of life are broken
because of all of the death and disease,
then you have this
incredible European century
of revival after the Black Death.
Meanwhile, dun-dun-dun!
Something very important
happens in Byzantium in 1453,
which is that...
- The Ottomans take it over.
- Yeah, it falls.
Finally, right? Finally.
Okay, from the West
European point of view,
it's a thousand years late, but...
And a thousand years, let's
face it, as a long time.
A thousand years late, but
it finally falls in 1453.
And it falls to the Ottoman
Empire, which is an entity
which we're going to
cover in the next lecture.
The Ottoman Empire is very
important for Ukraine.
In all these relationships,
which in our reading tend to
look like Poland and Russia,
you know, west and east, the hard part
to force into the story
is the southern part,
which is the Ottoman Empire
and the Crimean Khanate,
and I'm going to try to force
that in in the next lecture,
because none of it makes sense
without the Ottoman Empire.
But the Ottoman Empire
takes over Byzantium,
replaces Byzantium.
Istanbul becomes Constantinople,
and I was reminded by one of, like,
the many people who now
email me about this class
that They Might Be Giants
did not write that song.
Okay, I know they didn't write the song.
I was looking for, like, some reference
which maybe you guys would possibly get.
Probably failed.
But anyway, Istanbul
rather than Constantinople,
and what this means for Europe...
And this is where we get
to our world historical turning point.
What this means for Europe
is that the Ottoman Empire now controls
the standard trade routes to Asia.
And because the Ottoman Empire
controls the standard land routes to Asia,
if you're in a reviving Europe
and you need those trade
routes, what do you do?
You do crazy things.
Like, if you're England, you say,
"Hmm, maybe I could
find a passage to China
through the Arctic Ocean," right?
And then you find Russia instead.
Oh, and by the way, I mean,
this is another example of globalization.
When the Russians sweep through Asia,
basically in a hundred years,
I mean, it's incredibly fast,
they're doing that in part
because they have access
to European technology,
namely the musket, right?
The musket. Very simple gunpowder weapons.
They have access to that
because they also have contact
with the Atlantic World.
The Atlantic World comes in
and then they make their
way all to the Pacific
with a very simple
technological advantage.
I mean, summarizing it,
they go with muskets
and they collect tribute
in furs, mostly sable.
That's simplifying it, but
that's a big part of the truth.
And then they sell those sables
to China and around the world.
And so it's the...
And that is, in a microcosm, a big part
of the history of the Age of Discovery.
You have a technological edge
and you use that technological edge
to control a lot of
territory really quickly
while that technological edge lasts.
That technological edge will
eventually wear itself out,
and when it wears itself out,
then the tables are going
to be turned on you,
and all of your stories about
how you're superior are going
to turn out not to be so true, right?
It was the technological
edge, really. Okay.
So you do crazy things.
Like, you might, like, okay,
so you go over the Arctic Ocean.
Why not? That didn't work out.
But two other things did work out
which you've probably heard of,
like Vasco da Gama going
around the Horn of Africa
and finding his way and
defeating Arab sailors
and landing in South
Asia, in India, right,
for the Portuguese, and
Christopher Columbus,
with the even, if possible, wackier idea
of going across the Atlantic
Ocean to make his way to China,
or the Indies, rather,
and discovering, you know,
something else which he called the Indies.
And so it's now still
called the Indies, weirdly,
or it's now called America.
So all of these things, right?
The British, the Portuguese, the...
Columbus wasn't Spanish, but
it was a Spanish mission.
All of this is because of Ottoman Empire
blocking trade routes,
and the trade routes then
in turn generate new things.
So after these unexpected encounters
with new places in America,
there are new supplies of precious metals,
and of course there are new people
to colonize and to convert.
Now, I realize this isn't
really our main story,
but the reason why we have
to have this in the back
of our mind is because
we are in, as I've said,
we're entering into this world of empires,
and you can't understand
Ukraine inside empires
unless we understand what empires are
at this particular moment in history.
Okay, so some of this history
is going to be familiar
to you from other classes.
The leading imperial powers
at the very beginning
are Portugal and Spain.
They divide the whole world
between them ambitiously.
Spain destroys some other
really important states,
the Aztecs, the Incas,
kill maybe 10 million
people in the New World.
The Dutch rise and replace
to a large degree the Portuguese in Asia.
They take over the Cape
of Good Hope in 1652.
The Portuguese are pushed
back to Brazil. Okay.
And then this brings me
to a theme which I'm sure
you've kept in mind the
entire time, which is slavery.
So the nature of slavery...
Again, you know,
it's not like I'm going to
ask you this on the exam.
It's just that our history
fits into this larger history
and it helps the larger
history make sense.
So if you remember,
our history is partly about how slavery
in a certain part of the
world comes to an end.
The conversions to Christianity
are about slavery coming to an end.
When you convert to Christianity,
that is one of the first
things that happens.
Other Christians...
I mean, rules are
broken, but in principle,
other Christians are
not going to enslave you
and your neighboring Christian
powers are not going to think
they can raid your country
and enslave the population.
It's not the most glamorous
thing about Christianity,
and this is not the thing
that rises to the top
in the narrative of conversion, right?
But it's perhaps the fundamental thing.
If you create a Christian state,
other Christian states are not
going to enslave your people.
You've decided not to enslave your people.
You're going to tax them instead.
Very important, very important transition.
So our class in a way starts
with this riddle of slavery,
because you have to, like...
You can't get away from slavery.
If you're going to study human history,
you can't get away from slavery,
because at any moment where you try
to start history almost
anywhere in the world,
you then have to ask the question
of when you get from this
form of economic organization
to another form of economic
organization and why
and under what ideological
and political premises
and auspices, which is
a way of understanding
the first few lectures of this class.
This doesn't mean that slavery
comes to an end, of course.
What it means is that the slave markets,
like the Genoese one that
I mentioned in Kaffa,
the slave markets are
trading different people,
from the Caucasus, for example, from Asia,
and then, of course, from Africa.
The Ottomans are increasingly going
to be getting their slaves from Africa,
not that they won't enslave
Europeans occasionally,
but increasingly, they're going
to be getting their slaves from Africa.
And so this all connects, right?
Because the demand for slaves,
it's going to be present,
but where the slaves are
coming from is going to change.
And so again, I realize I've, like,
pounded this point into the ground,
but the language can help
you remember something
which subsequent events will then bury.
So our word for slave, right,
the English word for slave,
which comes from the
German Sklave, Sklave,
which comes from the Arabic
(speaking in Arabic),
and (speaking in Arabic)
comes from Slav, right?
Following the language can remind us
of an origin of something,
or an early phase of
something, let's call it,
that we might otherwise forget.
So this is connected to our class
because of the formation of states
and because of the spread
of Russian power southward,
which is going to be in the next lecture.
But as the Russian state moves southward,
enforcing serfdom, to be sure,
it becomes harder and harder to raid
for slaves in that direction.
So the slave markets or
the source of slaves,
in general, it's going to move southward.
And this coincides, this shift
coincides with the emergence
of the demand for slaves
in the New World, right?
And so then the slave markets are going
to shift to the New World.
The demand for slaves is
coming from the New World
as the slave trade in general has moved
southward towards Africa.
So again, this is not a connection
that we need to push too far.
It's just that I want you
to see that there is a kind
of logical chain of events,
and this larger question
of who belongs to the state
and who can be enslaved is a question
which you can follow if you want.
You don't have to.
I'm not going to make you do this.
But it's a question that you can follow
from the 10th century in Eastern Europe
to the 18th century in the United States
if you want to, right?
It's not just a logical question.
It's not just a kind of similarity.
It's also a chain of events
over time that one can follow.
Okay, so the African slave trade...
Yeah, so of course, like, the expansion
of the slave trade to Africa
involves massive death
and trauma, including by suicide,
the destruction of local states
and local cultural groups,
the destruction of the position of women.
It slows down.
The trade slows down in
the late 18th century,
early 19th century, as first the French
and then the British end
the African slave trade.
The slave trade in the
Ottoman Empire comes
to an end in 1882.
The Civil War in the
United States is in 1863.
Okay, so what I...
The last thing that I want to do
is to try to bring the history of empire
through the period where we are now
a little bit into the
18th and 19th centuries
so that you can then, as we do the 17th,
18th, and 19th centuries in Ukraine,
you'll have a kind of world
perspective of what's going on.
I'm going to again pause and
ask if I'm going too quickly
and see if there are any questions.
Just taking the feel of the room here.
Okay, you're all at the edge
of your seats. That's good.
The camera can't see
whether you're on the
edge of your seats or not,
so I can just, like, say stuff like that.
Okay, so after Spain...
So the first wave, Spain and Portugal,
are the most important,
and then the Netherlands
is the most important,
and then it's going to be
the British and the French
who are the most
important colonial powers.
In the 18th century, it's
going to be the British
and the French who are
competing for world domination.
A side effect of the
British-French competition
for world domination
is this country, right?
If you remember the sort of general thesis
that states can come into existence
because of a sort of friction
between two greater powers,
in the case of the
United States of America,
that would be the friction
between the British
and the French empires.
It's particularly a side effect
of what the world calls
the Seven Years' War
but which American history
calls the French and Indian War,
slightly obscurely.
So that war, 1756 to 1763,
which is also a European
war, and we'll get to it,
is when the French and
the British redivide
and where it's going to be clear
that the British control Canada,
the British control India.
It was the threat of the French
that kept these colonies,
the American colonies, close to Britain.
When the French threat was removed,
then, structurally, the
colonies could start
to relax their attitude
towards the British.
It made rebellion possible.
And then, of course, the French came in
at the end of the Revolutionary War.
Now, why is that interesting?
I mean, because, you
know, American history,
I don't know about you guys, but okay,
well, okay, maybe it's really interesting.
Okay, I find it more
interesting all the time.
I admit it.
I find American history more
interesting all the time.
But one of the things which
is interesting about 1776
is that it's Europeans liberating
themselves from Europeans,
Europeans who are defined as colonists
liberating themselves from
a European empire, right?
And as they liberate themselves,
they of course preserve
longer than the imperial power
one of the features of the
empire, which was slavery, right?
But so it's an interesting
moment where Europeans are,
people of European
origin define themselves
as an independent state
and they actually win.
Now, I just want you to mark the 1776 date
because the 1776 date,
that's when the
Revolutionary War took place
in the United States.
Then you're in the same
world historical moment
not just as the French Revolution,
okay, I admit that's important too,
but you're also in the
same historical moment
as the end of the Kazakh state,
which we're going to get
to in the next lecture,
and you're in the same historical moment
as the end of the
Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth.
So back in Europe, you're in
a moment where this question
of European empires controlling
Europeans is also relevant
but in a slightly different direction.
So one way to think about
the end of the 18th century
is that it's an interesting
moment of exchange
involving European empires
and European empires
controlling Europeans.
It's also an interesting moment about...
So roughly at the same time is the moment
when the Ottoman Empire starts
to withdraw from Europe.
The first couple of decades
of the 19th century,
the Ottoman Empire is going
to be withdrawing from Europe,
and that power is going to
cease to be an imperial power
over part of the Balkans,
Greece, and Serbia.
Okay, the next thing...
And I realize this is a lot.
I hope this, like, feels
more like entertainment
than, you know, than oppression,
or at least ideally
entertaining oppression.
But the next thought
that I want you to have,
it has to do with how
empire continues to work
in the world in the age of nationalism.
So it's very easy to say
the nation is against the empire, right?
And that's a very convenient
sort of position to be in
because in that case, empire
bad, nation good, right?
Empire big, nation small.
Empire old, nation new. Right?
The nation can start fresh,
has no historical baggage, all of that.
But the truth is that in the 19th century,
empire and nation are very much
entangled with one another.
So when Jefferson describes
the United States, for example,
as an empire of liberty,
that doesn't, I mean,
that doesn't really make
any sense conceptually,
but you can see why he's saying it.
It is because the United
States is an empire,
and you know, the liberty
part is restrained
to a certain group, of course.
On the European continent,
maybe the best example
of this entanglement
are the Napoleonic Wars.
On the European continent, the
idea that you can start fresh
is most closely associated
with the French Revolution.
The idea that we're now in a new period
where we understand humanity
and we have a science of humanity
and we can start fresh, we're enlightened,
is most strongly associated
with the French Revolution.
And when the French Revolution
leads to Napoleon Bonaparte,
the notion of his wars across Europe
is that these are wars
of national liberation.
And that's not entirely false.
All over Europe, he, you know,
dispatches his various brothers-in-law
and they start new countries
with new names and new currencies,
and Napoleon is seen by many
people as a national liberator.
But at the same time,
what Napoleon is building
is also an empire
where the metropole is
clearly going to be Paris.
So you have this ambiguity
about what is national
and what is imperial and
how the two work together.
And you also have this very powerful idea
which is characteristic of
the 19th century and forward
that I can build an empire
by talking about your national liberation.
The French pioneer that,
not just Napoleon Bonaparte,
but actually Napoleon
II in the 1860s, 1870s.
1859 is really when it starts.
I can create an empire by
liberating you nationally.
I mean, I don't even have to tell you
how much continuity that
idea has had, right?
Right down to the war in
Ukraine, because after all,
what is one of the core Russian arguments
for why they're invading Ukraine?
That in fact, Ukrainians
need to be liberated
nationally from other empires,
that what's really happening
in Ukraine is that...
Okay, it's not the Habsburgs anymore,
but it's still the Poles
and it's also the Americans
and the European Union and so on.
Someone else has made an empire,
and I'm going to liberate you nationally.
You may not be aware that
this is what is happening,
but this is what is happening.
And so it's not really an empire.
I'm actually liberating you nationally.
And so that argument,
which comes out of the
middle of the 19th century
and particularly out of
France, is very powerful.
And another connection
between the national
and the imperial is the economic one.
So Marx and Engels, who
you may have heard of,
had this idea that the workers
of the world would unite.
You've heard of that, right?
1848, "Communist Manifesto."
One of the problems with this,
as Marx and Engels had to wrestle with,
is that the workers of one country
could be very much in favor of imperialism
because from their point of view,
imperial control over other
territories kept prices down,
created other economic opportunities,
opportunities for
immigration and so on, right?
So you could be a worker,
but you wouldn't necessarily sympathize
with a worker in another country
because your country is
exploiting another country
and that has improved
your standard of living.
And so in that way,
nationalism and imperialism
could work together
because the working classes
could become more national
because their countries were empires,
which is something which
got tangled up in Britain
and is still before our
eyes being disentangled.
Empire could be seen...
In other words, as mass
politics comes into existence
and as workers and others get to vote
and as workers and others
can take part in politics,
empire could be seen as a
solution to social problems.
And so in this way, nation and
empire also get tangled up.
Okay, let me just bring this
through the 19th century
and say a word about land
empires and sea empires,
and then I promise you we will be done.
By the time we get to
the late 19th century,
who is a land empire
and who is a sea empire
has more or less been sorted out.
Russia is a European
and Asian land empire.
It controls Poland and Finland
as well as all these territories
down through the Pacific.
Actually, it controls California
into the 19th century.
The Americans after 1823
and the Monroe Doctrine
see themselves as controlling
the Western Hemisphere.
The Russians are stopped
from becoming a world maritime
empire by the Japanese,
who are a non-European country
which defeats a European country
in war in 1904 and in in 1905.
That's one of the kinds of lines
when empires run out of territory,
is when the Russians lose to the Japanese.
The very last thing which happens
in the European imperial
history is the race for Africa.
So Japan is a line which isn't
crossed by the Europeans.
The Japanese defend themselves
and promptly build their own
version of empire in East Asia.
The very last step in European empire
is the race for Africa,
which is the late 1800s,
the late 19th century.
And the way the race for
Africa works is that...
It's interesting.
After slavery is no longer profitable
because the slave trade has been banned,
the countries which are
on the West African coast
push further into Africa
in pursuit of other things
to trade and make different
kinds of arrangements,
very often also involving domination,
with the states that they find there.
And so the end of the slave trade,
in this kind of historical irony,
leads to a different form of exploitation
which now involves territory,
because if you're trading
agricultural goods
or mineral goods, then you
want to control territory.
If you're trading slaves,
you just have to have
connections on the coast.
But so what happens is
the slave trade morphs
into trade in minerals
and agricultural goods,
which requires control of territory,
and so then we have this race for Africa
which takes place 1870s, 1890s, 1900s.
And it's at that moment when
Germany joins the French
and the English and also the Portuguese
and the Spanish and so on, the Dutch,
as an imperial power beyond
the boundaries of Europe.
Why does that matter?
And this is really the closing thought.
Of course it matters in and of itself.
I mean, the history of Africa
is absolutely fascinating.
But it also matters because of the way
that Africa affects the
European imagination
of what empire is going to be.
And now, you know, now we're getting
towards the end of the class.
The purpose of this lecture has been
to kind of just prepare
the way for thinking
about empire in the context of Ukraine.
But because the race for Africa happens
in the late 19th century,
it influences the way that Europeans think
about how they're going to colonize Europe
when Europeans start to
colonize Europe again
in the 20th century.
In the First World War,
when the Germans and the
Austrians control Ukraine,
they will have no hesitation whatever
in seeing Ukraine as a breadbasket,
which is the phrase which
is used, Kornkammer.
"Ukraine is a breadbasket.
Ukraine is going to feed us.
The peasants will have
no trouble with this.
They're going to love it,"
which turns out not to
be true, incidentally.
The peasants don't love it.
So the German and Austrian plan
for winning the First World War
was "We're going to take the grain,
we're going to take the
grain from the Ukrainians,
and then we're going to
feed our own civilians,
they'll be happy, and we're
going to feed our soldiers
and they'll win on the Western Front."
That's the plan.
It doesn't work out
because the Ukrainian peasants
don't play their role.
But to make a long story
short, and don't worry,
I'll tell the longer version,
Hitler thinks this too.
Hitler thinks that
Ukraine is a Kornkammer.
It's a breadbasket.
It's an unlimited supply of food.
He thinks that the Ukrainian peasants are,
in his imagination, the
way that the Africans are,
and his analogies towards Ukraine,
although he has many, he
uses India, he uses America,
he applies India and America as well,
but the main way he thinks about Ukraine
is from a colonial imaginary
that comes from Africa.
So he describes the Ukrainians
in Africanizing terms
for a very simple reason.
This is when Hitler grew up.
This is the kind of European
imperialism which was going on.
Those are the colonies that Germany lost
in the First World War,
were African colonies.
So all down the line,
until we get to the end
of this class, it matters,
you know, it matters in three ways,
as I've been trying to say,
that the period between,
let's say, 1500 and 1950 is
a period of European empire.
It matters because events
happen on a different pace,
that things simply are connected in a way
that they aren't before 1500.
It matters because of the
various ways people can think
about the world now that
the world is all connected.
But thirdly, it also
matters because of the kind
of empire or the ideas of
empire that are relevant.
Neither Hitler, and we'll get to this,
nor Stalin could've thought about Ukraine
the way that they did without
the European domination
of the rest of the world.
Hitler thinks of Ukraine
in an Africanizing way.
When Stalin thinks of Ukraine, he says,
"We don't have far-flung maritime empire
the way the British and the French do.
Therefore, we have to carry out something
called internal colonization," right?
So that thought, how
everyone judges that thought,
that thought is not possible
without the existence,
the transparent example,
the simple everyday
facticity of European empire.
Okay, so as I say, I hope that
that wasn't too oppressive
and that if it was oppressive,
it was also at least
somewhat entertaining.
This is background, right?
This is structure.
These are things that,
if we have them in mind,
it will help make some of the events
in our region make more sense.
And don't worry.
I'm going to get back to the
Kazaks and the Ottoman Empire
and the Crimean Tatars
in earnest on Tuesday.
I'm looking forward to it.
Thanks for being here.
(soft music)